what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have our very last apparently
eternals trailer titled the final
trailer now i'm pretty sure we're going
to get like a billion tv spots after
this so no worries about that and i'm
sure we'll get 2 billion more before we
actually get the spider-man no way home
trailer but in the meantime let's talk
about this pretty epic eternals trailer
in this eternals trailer we actually get
a few questions that we've been having
for a long time now answered like when
does this exactly take place after the
blip before the blip why didn't the
eternals ever interfere in any of the
events on earth where the earth could
have been destroyed a lot of these
questions have been answered and i'm
afraid that a plot leak that got out not
too long ago could be real and i think
this is bad news for ajax ajax is played
by salma hayek and is the leader of the
eternals now she talks a lot during this
trailer but if you notice we really only
see her in the beginning when the
eternals first show up about 7 000 years
ago as they state in the trailer and
then on her ranch and besides that we
don't really see her now this is marvel
and this could be to throw us off we
know that they edit their trailers
differently so we don't know everything
that's going to happen in the movies but
if you take a look at all of these
scenes happening in the present day we
don't see ajax anywhere and we do know
that richard madden's character icarus
does visit her on the farm we see that
in this trailer and we also see his
powers yesterday all of the eternals his
powers for the most part were revealed
and icarus's powers are the ability of
flight and to shoot beams of light from
his eyes now this so-called light is
most likely just cosmic energy as we see
him fight several deviants in this
trailer and he rips them in half with
his energy and we see the light energy
coming out of his eyes on the ranch so
it could be that the deviants actually
attack ajac and icarus on the ranch or
there is always the possibility that
icarus could actually be bad i really
hope this isn't the case because i hope
he goes on to be a prominent member of
marvel during this new phase and i
really hope ajax doesn't die i hope they
didn't bring salma hayek into the mcu
just to kill her off kind of early on in
the movie but it does definitely look
like something is happening on her ranch
where icarus has to use his powers and
again we don't ever see her in the
present time so we'll have to see about
that one just something i noticed right
away off the bat i hope marvel's
tricking us on this one but let's get
into the shot by shot and if you love
marvel and want to stay up to date be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any video so it starts off with ajax
riding a horse back to her ranch it
looks like she's made a decent life for
herself she has a pretty big land there
and we can see far away next to her
house icarus is standing there waiting
for her here we find out that this is
really going to take place for the most
part five years after the blip she says
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe and then she
says but the people of this planet
brought everybody back with the snap of
a finger and i think this is actually
very specific language he's using here
because thanos erased half of the
population of the entire universe not
just our very specific earth but she is
referring to our specific people she
said the people of this planet brought
everybody back and remember the eternals
were kind of sent to earth to protect
earth we know the story is going to be
different in the movies but that is
their comic origin that's why they were
created by the celestials which we'll
get into in a second but it really does
seem like ajax is admiring the humans in
this scene thanos for years and years
and years conquered the universe and
remember thanos is actually an eternal
and a deviant who the eternals are going
to be fighting so they more than likely
knew what he was doing in the universe
so the whole universe gets wiped away
half of it at least and our heroes the
people of our planet the avengers
stepped in and returned it back to
normal snapped everybody back showing
how great humans really are however
unfortunately ajax says the sudden
return of the population provided the
necessary energy for the emergence to
begin in which ajax says they only have
seven days now the emergence isn't that
clearly defined but it does seem like
it's an apocalyptic event where the
deviants are going to destroy the world
now i do have a big theory right here
about what the emergence is actually
going to do and i do believe it's going
to start to introduce mutants to the
world you see the eternals and the
celestials that created the eternals are
connected to the mutants the celestials
originally came to earth and created
both of the deviants and the eternals
the celestials essentially performed
genetic experiments on the early early
humans the very first humans this would
ultimately lead to genetic mutations
that would give some human superpowers
and i believe that we could be
witnessing some sort of a combination in
the eternals of how the mutants are
formed in the mcu like ajax said the
snap of bringing everybody back provided
the necessary energy for the emergence
to begin and if we take a look at that
exact moment it looks like some type of
cosmic energy is happening as they are
being brought back perhaps this energy
could awaken the latent mutant gene
inside of people this gene could have
come from the eternals being created and
humans being experimented on by the
celestials and i actually believe this
is kind of hinted to when they show when
the movie is coming out it says november
but if you take a look inside of the o
in november very briefly you can see a
double helix so it looks like it's dna
and it quickly disappears it's only
there for a little bit and of course
this is hinting at the dna of the
eternals of the deviants because their
dna was experimented on it was altered
by the celestials to create them and i
believe the implications of this are
going to go a lot further in the mcu all
the way to mutants being introduced we
know the mutants are coming kevin feige
mentioned the x-men at san diego
comic-con several years ago now and i
believe that the eternals could be a key
part in how the mutants come to the mcu
but let me know what you think about
this theory down below now from here in
the trailer we get sort of an origin
story about the eternals and how they
came to earth cersei is talking to dane
whitman and yesterday in entertainment
weekly's article that they released
about the eternals they confirmed that
cersei and dane whitman are indeed
dating but they also did confirm that
cersei and icarus have been dating
pretty much on and off again throughout
the seven thousand years so we'll see
how that works and more on that in a bit
but this is clearly right after dane
whitman finds out about cersei he finds
out that she is some supernatural person
and now she is explaining to him what
exactly she is she says we're eternals
we came here 7 000 years ago to protect
earth from the deviants and as she's
explaining this we get a few scenes one
is all of the eternals sitting around
one of the celestials apparently not
moving at all not awake all wearing the
same clothing now there was a plot leak
that said the eternals could be an
artificial intelligence just a super
advanced artificial intelligence and the
way that this energy from the celestial
goes inside of ajac in this scene and
awakens her that could actually be the
case i don't necessarily think that
they're robots but i think the
celestials could have designed their
bodies created their bodies and then
this energy is sort of like a soul
because this is the ability that the
eternals have they have the ability to
control cosmic energy each eternal can
control it in a different way but that
is each of their's main ability
controlling cosmic energy now this could
also be some sort of a ritual that they
do when they communicate with the
celestials and the energy could be the
celestials communicating with them we'll
have to wait and see on that but some
other things that we see is their ship
flying insanely close to a sun taking no
damage at all so it's clearly made out
of something insane and it's clear that
the eternals actually come to earth on
their ship so they weren't actually
created on earth so i'm curious to where
they were actually created perhaps they
could be coming from titan if you recall
in infinity war thanos said his home
planet was titan well titan is actually
home planet to the eternals thanos was
born to two eternal parents but he
inherited a deviant gene so in this
sense thanos was essentially an eternal
and a deviant so they're already
referencing him a bit in this trailer so
i'm pretty sure he's going to come up a
few times in this movie
we then get a shot of icarus powers now
like i said he can shoot cosmic light
from his eyes but he can also fly now
each eternal like i said can control
cosmic energy but they also have their
own special unique abilities and this is
clearly his and i get major superman
vibes from this which i actually really
like now here dane whitman asks a very
important question that we've all
actually been asking why didn't you guys
help fight thanos or any war or all of
the other terrible things throughout
history that have happened in which
cersei responds we were instructed not
to interfere in any of the events of
humans unless deviants were involved and
then dane and whitman asked by who and
we see a celestial now as i mentioned in
this trailer the celestials created the
eternals and they also created the
deviants at least in the comics they did
and the celestials are cosmic gods we
saw one in guardians of the galaxy we
saw s on the searcher and based off of
the face the six eyes that we have there
it kind of does look like us on the
searcher however this particular
celestial is very very red which leads
me to believe that it could be arishim
areshem is known as ereshem the judge
and he's actually the leader of the
celestials at least the celestials on
earth yes the eyes are different than
his in the comics in the comics he has
more of horizontal eyes instead of
circles but it's either s on the
searcher or irishman so it's clear that
the eternals have wanted to help out
it's clear that many of them have
actually taken a liking to humans and
would have liked to protect them we see
some of them watching over the humans as
terrible events happen and we even see
fastas crying but it's very clear that
they can't interfere unless deviants are
involved even though in the last trailer
we learned that the eternals actually
helped humanity get started they kind of
helped civilization evolved in the
beginning they essentially created
babylon so it looks like they kind of
helped them get started and then kind of
dipped again probably because of the
celestial's orders but now the deviants
are coming to basically destroy the
earth so it's time to step in again now
it's important to note that dane whitman
played by kit harrington in the comics
is black knight and i know a lot of
people are really excited to see him in
the eternals however i do not think that
he is going to become the black knight
in this film i think it's going to be a
setup for him to appear later on in the
mcu unfortunately but it's still
exciting nonetheless at least we know
that he won't die during the movie and
if he does that's a huge waste of a
really really great actor and a really
great character now icarus says that
they have to find the rest of the
eternals and ajax says i haven't seen
some of them for centuries and we figure
out what some of them have been up to we
see drew again he is basically a cult
leader at this point he has the ability
to manipulate people's thoughts so
essentially control minds and we can see
all the people that he's influencing
he's basically given up on humanity and
is trying a different way to kind of
have everything civilized we then see
sprite pull out a dagger and sprite may
look like a little kid but sprite is
just as old as everybody else just
trapped in a little kid's body
essentially sprite has the ability to
channel cosmic energy like all of the
other eternals but sprite also has the
ability to levitate herself and create
illusions sprite is often known as the
trickster of the group we then see
angelina jolie's thena and don lee's
gilgamesh in which angelina jolie takes
a weapon out of nothing and gilgamesh
blocks it this is tina's specific power
she is able to create weapons out of
thin air out of nothing she is the
warrior of the group but gilgamesh is
the strongest of the group and he
specializes in hand-to-hand combat which
is why he simply just blocks the spear
we then see some of the eternals
together we see king sprite icarus and
cersei and then of course there's
gilgamesh and then not in the shot but
ajax is not here hopefully she's dealing
with something and isn't dead we then
hear sprite say if this is what the end
of the world looks like at least we have
front row seats and during this scene we
actually see some of the eternals appear
out of nowhere now sprite is the first
one to appear so this could be an
illusion caused by her either that or
the eternals can manipulate cosmic
energy in a way that turns them
invisible or perhaps they're even
teleporting but i'm more leaning towards
the fact that it could be sprite's
illusion or they're turning invisible
from here fastas pulls out the ship he
is the engineer and the inventor of the
eternals group he probably has a lot to
do with the upkeeping of the ship and
then we see some of the eternals on the
ship all of them are now essentially
together except for ajak we have a sing
with kingo fastos druid and makari now
makari's ability is she is super fast
and she's also deaf and it's really cool
because this is actually going to be the
first deaf actress playing a major
superhero role we can see on the ship
that they have collected many artifacts
over time which we saw in the last
trailer as well cut to angelina jolie
saying that they've loved these people
all their lives and when you love
something you protect it in which right
when she says that we conveniently see
icarus looking at searsie but then
another scene where cersei is protecting
dane whitman as i mentioned before
yesterday an entertainment weekly
article did confirm that over the 7 000
years cersei and icarus have been
together they've been on and off pretty
much for 7 000 years the ultimate on and
off relationship it's clear that icarus
very much loves cersei but cersei does
share love for humanity and it is
confirmed that she is going to be dating
dane whitman in this movie so there is
definitely a love triangle here and it
looks like it's definitely going to be
addressed in the film in this scene we
actually see sarzi transform a bus into
flower petals that's because cersei's
ability is to be able to manipulate
non-sentient matter so matter that isn't
alive and apparently her manipulation
goes a very long way as she was able to
turn a bus into flower petals that's not
just controlling things with your mind
this is on another level we then see
cersei in what looks to be the inside of
the ship where she activates it
now from here we see a lot of action
sequences of the deviants attacking and
we actually learn who the main villain
of the eternals is it's the deviant crow
he's fighting angelina jolie and he
seems to have overtaken her and he says
you can't protect any of them crow is
the general of the deviants and he's
actually almost more of an eternal than
he is a deviant he actually has the
ability to be able to shapeshift making
him a pretty big threat but perhaps one
of the biggest things here with theena
and crow is that in the comics they are
actually secret lovers in the comics
tina and crow actually have kids twins
but thena tries to keep this a secret
and gives them to an infertile woman for
her to raise we obviously don't know at
this point if that's going to be a
storyline in the eternals but we'll have
to wait and see although crow is
brushing the side of her face and she
turns her head kind of like this has
been done for a while it used to be
something but now it's nothing get over
yourself so this very well could be a
thing in the eternals movie the trailer
ends with some superman scenes and some
of the eternals at fastos's house icarus
making a statement that fastos's house
must be a pretty big safe house and the
table must be made out of vibranium but
fasto says that it's from ikea hahaha
but seriously this movie does look
pretty freaking fantastic and i am super
stoked for this so let me know what you
think about it in the comments down
below are you excited for this movie did
this impress you let me know don't
forget to subscribe for more marvel and
eternals videos and don't forget to hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
any videos if you enjoyed the video give
it a like and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof